За роки війни на Сході України держава невпинно
посилює свою обороноздатність. Частково завдяки
великим міжнародним військовим навчанням,
як, приміром, Rapid Trident чи Sea Breeze.
Але головним чином - за рахунок модернізації армії та озброєнь.
Новинки українського оборонпрому українцям,
зокрема, продемонстрували на параді до Дня незалежності.
Утім, чи справді всі ці новинки вже нині посилюють
обороноздатність держави?
6 типів із новинок української військової промисловості,
вперше показаних на параді у 2018 році,
наявні в українських військах.
Допущені до експлуатації в ЗСУ:
бронемашини "Варта",
БТР-3ДА,
безпілотники "Фурія", "Лелека", "ПД-1",
модернізований танк Т-64 БВ.
Процедуру допущення до експлуатації техніки у війську
без тривалих державних випробувань і прийняття на озброєння
запровадили 2015 року, щоб техніка швидше
опинялася в армії за умов російської агресії.
Реактивна система залпового вогню "Вільха"
зроблена на основі радянського "Смерчу".
Випробування вже пройдені, через кілька місяців "Вільха"
має з'явитися у війську. Буде налагоджене серійне виробництво.
Танк T-84 "Ятаган" брав участь у конкурсі
на постачання танків до Туреччини ще у 2000-му році.
Військово-транспортний літак Ан-178 має замінити
"Ани" попереднього покоління.
Він готовий до серійного виробництва.
Комплекс артилерійської розвідки "Положення-2"
прийнятий на озброєння ще у 2013 році.
Через процес заміни компонентів російського виробництва
лише тепер завершено підготовку до його серійного випуску.
Усіх цих зразків техніки немає в ЗСУ:
вони існують поки лише в одиничному екземплярі.
Найбільше суперечок викликали так звані
перспективні зразки на параді.
Ходовий макет ракетного комплексу
оперативно-тактичного призначення
з високою точністю ураження "Сапсан"
розробляли останні 10 років. Активна фаза розробки триває два роки.
Фахівці стверджують, що орієнтовно лише за 3 роки
новий ракетний комплекс може бути прийнятий на озброєння.
Ще більш невизначена ситуація
з українською колісною самохідною гаубицею "Богдана".
На полігонах проходять випробування
кілька варіантів нової української гаубиці і поки невідомо,
як виглядатиме після випробувань зразок,
рекомендований до серійного виробництва.